it is impossible to overstate the mental
scarring of the survivors of gym around
there Peter lived in the home until the
age of four when the nuns sold him on to
a violent family by that time he'd lost
his sister she liked nearly eight
hundred others had her name recorded in
a death register to walk on this plot is
to walk over the bones infant children
for a Catholic organization to put
bodies in here there were baptized
registered baptized yet the bottom in
her own consecrated ground and left them
here like animals no respect no records
no nothing savages forever like all the
others Petrova's grandmother had to give
her sons up to the nuns as punishments
for becoming pregnant outside marriage
both of them but Rovers two uncles died
John Francis only made a week apparently
they didn't feed him your uncle's names
on this list yes yeah he's right here
John Francis Malone seven days and the
death certificate says that he died of
malnutrition
well it says more asthma starvation
essentially so so so he starved to death
yeah he did in the care of the nuns yeah
like many others petrova believes the
whole place is a crime scene there's
still an awful lot of unanswered
questions and without those questions
being answered then how do we know it's
not it's five years since a local
historian uncovered the scale of what
happened here and the government has
promised to excavate the site a
preliminary investigation discovered
skeletons lined up in rows
since the entrance is very narrow it's
led to the suspicion that the nuns got
the children to carry the bodies of dead
babies down the pit after these photos
were taken the whole site was covered
over again the government minister
responsible for all this declined an
interview but the government's own
interim reports suggest that they don't
trust the testimonies of surviving nuns
and they think that local people might
know more than they've been prepared to
admit in the meantime though the
detective work is being done
not by the police but by the survivors
of Tim and their families the
campaigners think the government is so
frightened of the damage to the church
that a full excavation would do that it
is resisting it so they're threatening
court action I think the only way in
which this will be resolved is through
an order of the superior courts of this
country I can't see any other way
because there is no will
there's no wish there is no appetite
church and state in this country are
still wedded in a poisonous pact there
are thought to be dozens and dozens of
other places like this around Ireland a
full investigation into the scale of
what happened across all the country's
mother and baby homes would be explosive
and could destroy the reputation of the
church hardly surprised then the
survivors think the government would
rather bury the truth than dig up the
past
Lawrence Lee Al Jazira tomb in Ireland